COLT MCANLIS: One
important part of writing
successful applications
is enabling the programmer
to be as efficient as
possible so that they
can focus their brain cycles on
the truly important problems.
But sometimes this
ease of development
can create new
performance problems
that aren't always clear.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And while the Android
Runtime provides
lots of opportunities
for programmers
to be more efficient,
it also presents
a lot of hidden pitfalls
with respect to performance.
And the single biggest one
that you need to worry about
has everything to do with how
you're allocating and using
memory.
See, many programming languages
that are known for being "high
performance," like a C and C++,
usually require programmers
to manage memory themselves.
That is, the programmer is
responsible for allocating
blocks of memory off of the
heap during code execution,
and explicitly freeing
them back to the heap
once they aren't
being used anymore.
But in a 2 million
line code base,
it's easy to get
lost in logic flows
and end up not freeing
allocated memory as intended.
These types of allocations
are called leaks-- that is,
memory which was
allocated but never freed.
Now, a managed memory
environment, on the other hand,
removes this burden of freeing
memory from the programmer's
shoulders.
See, it keeps track of
each memory allocation.
And once it determines
that a piece of memory
is no longer being
used by the program,
it can free it back to the
heap without any intervention
from the programmer.
Which is great, because we can
spend that extra time doing
other things-- like arguing
about whether or not
crossguards work
on light sabers.
Anyhow, the process
of reclaiming
memory in a managed environment
is known as Garbage Collection.
It's a concept that was created
by John McCarthy back in 1959
to solve problems in the
LISP programming language.
And it generally adheres
to two primary principles--
find data objects in a program
that cannot be accessed
by in the future, and reclaim
the resources used by those
objects.
Now, think about it.
Garbage Collection
can be really gnarly.
I mean, if you've got
some 20,000 allocations
in your program
right now, which ones
aren't being needed anymore?
Or better yet, when should you
execute a Garbage Collection
event to free up memory
that isn't being used?
These are actually very
difficult questions.
And thankfully, we've had about
50 years worth of innovation
to improve on them.
Which is why the Garbage
Collector in Android Runtime
is quite a bit more
sophisticated than McCarthy's
original proposal.
It's been built to be fast and
as non-intrusive as possible.
Effectively, the memory
heap in Android's Runtime
are segmented into spaces
based on the type of allocation
and how best the system can
organize those allocations
for future GC events.
As a new object is allocated,
the characteristics
are taken into
account to best fit
what space it should
be placed into,
depending on what version of the
Android Runtime you're using.
And here's the important part.
Each space has a set size.
As objects are
allocated, we keep
track of the combined sizes.
And as a space starts
to grow, the system
will need to execute a Garbage
Collection event in an attempt
to free up memory for
future allocations.
Now, it's worth pointing
out that GC events will
behave differently depending
on which Android Runtime
you're using.
For example, in
DALVIK, many GC events
are "stop the world" events.
Meaning that any managed
code that is running
will stop until the
operation completes.
Which can get very
problematic when
these GCs take
longer than normal,
or there's a ton of
them happening at once,
since it's going to
significantly eat
into your frame time.
Now, ART, on the
other hand, extended
the functionality of a
concurrent GC system, which
tends to remove the larger
GC pauses, but will still
incur a small pause at the
end of important GC events.
And to be clear, our engineers
have spent a lot of time
making sure that
these events are
as fast as possible to
reduce interruptions.
That being said, this can
still cause your application
some performance headaches.
Firstly, understand that
the more time your app
is spending doing
GCs in a given frame,
the less time it's got
for the rest of the logic
needed to keep you under
the 16 millisecond barrier
for rendering.
So if you've got a lot
of GCs, or some long ones
right after each other, it might
push your frame processing time
over the 16 millisecond
barrier, which
can cause a visible hitching
or jink for your users.
Secondly, understand
that your code flow
may be doing the
kinds of work that
force GCs to occur more often
or making them last longer
than normal durations.
For example, if
you're allocating
a horde worth of objects in
the innermost part of a loop
that runs for a
really long time,
then you're going to be
polluting your memory
heap with a lot of objects.
And you'll end up kicking
off a lot of GC events
quickly due to this
additional memory pressure.
And these types of programming
patterns are easier to run into
than you'd think.
So thankfully, the
Android SDK has
a set of powerful
tools at your disposal.
For example, you can
get a high-level view
of how your application
is managing memory using
the Memory Monitor tool
inside of Android Studio.
Every time you see a dip
in the allocated memory,
that's a GC event occurring.
Lots of dips in a
short time could
signal a performance problem.
And you can see what objects
are active in your heap,
and what parts of your
code are allocating them,
with the Heap and Allocation
Tracker tools as well.
But wrangling memory
into performant uses
is easier said than done.
Which is why you need to check
out the rest of our Android
Performance Patterns
content for other great ways
to improve performance.
And don't forget to join our
Google+ community for excellent
info as well.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
Perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]